it was the centerpiece of the golden
summer of 2012 their new of some of the
finest moments in British sporting
history but the legacy of london's
olympic stadium is proving less glorious
sky news can reveal that the cost of the
arena has soared to more than 750
million pounds 51 million pounds more
than previously known London Mayor Sadiq
Khan is so concerned he has ordered an
investigation into the stadium's
finances and the deal by which West Ham
pay just 2.5 million pounds a year in
rent his deputy says blame lies with
former mayor boris johnson last year the
previous administration told the public
that the costs had risen in total to
around 270 million the mayor is now the
new mayor has now been told that that
cost will be over 320 million
understandably Sadiq because ordered an
investigation into exactly why those two
figures are so wildly different the
mayor announces investigation after we
learned of the problems with the
retractable seats to convert this
stadium from football to athletics these
retractable stands are supposed to push
back revealing the Athletics track
underneath but it's turned out to be a
lot more complicated than planned
problems with all four size of the
ground but particularly here in the East
Stand mean the current estimate is it
will take 15 days to move the stands
back and another 15 days push them
forward again and that the entire
operation could cost up to 8 million
pounds the original estimate for moving
them was just three hundred thousand
pounds a year in fact it will cost more
than three times West Ham's annual rent
and this is why rather than sliding on
wheels or a bed of air the stands have
built on the track and have to be moved
manually if it takes a month it will put
the stadium summer schedule including
concerts the world athletics
championships and even the start of the
next football season in jeopardy experts
say there is no easy solution they
should have brought them in early asked
them to help them design a main stand
spend all the money on the main stand
and then put up a temporary structure
for a fight night you was only using
this temporary structure for a fortnight
and they've spent best but I have a
billion pounds on it it's ludicrous
there is only one solution I'm terribly
sorry to say it you've gotta knock it
down and start again otherwise you'll
just have this dog's dinner for the next
40 years West Ham's moved to the stadium
has already been marred by violence
including last week when Chelsea visited
and police battled to keep rival fans
apart and coins were thrown at children
football at the Olympic Stadium was
always an uneasy fit the spiraling costs
and the mayor's investigation means the
questions will continue pull kelso Sky
News